[Music]
[Applause]
all right so what am I going to try and
do today in the 30 minutes I have
available the impossible is the answer
and so what I'm really going to do is
just introduce you to an idea the idea
of dirty hands and then say a few things
about it show you how it is part and
parcel of our general cultural
understanding of what goes on it's part
of how we understand our moral reality
despite the fact that moral theorists
think it's a very bad idea and then at
the end I'm going to give you an actual
example in Germany of something that
looks like a dirty hands case that was
dealt with by the law and then I would
like to hear what you have to say about
what your intuitions are whether you
think this is plausible because a lot of
people who think that what I'm about to
say to you is just flat wrong incoherent
and other people seem to think not only
you can hear it it's dangerous what I'm
going to say so it isn't enscombe
very famous philosopher said people even
contemplate this kind of thing show a
corrupt mind so I'm bringing you into a
world of corruption here if you are with
Elizabeth Anscombe that's it's it's not
quite as exciting as that sorry alright
so let's start and see where we are
let's start with a claim is it possible
to do a morally wrong action in order to
do what is morally required seems a very
weird thing to ask sounds either
paradoxical or just incoherent or just
sheer nonsense no it's like saying are
they married bachelors are they square
circles if I was to stand up here and
say let's have a chat about married
bachelors you'd be well within your
rights to think he's a nutter and get up
and leave right and you might still
think this but hang on a moment
right so what's going on here why why
would that view somehow make an
appearance within moral theory what's
going on there and what I'm going to try
and do is paint a picture for you of why
that might be plausible in moral theory
not only plausible
and avoidable in moral theory and
specifically in politics right so the
different reactions to what I've just
said to you there the moral theories
that I mentioned who are deeply worried
not all but most are deeply worried
about what I've just told you they think
that I'm misleading you and it's deeply
problematic consequentialists people who
think that you judge morality by the
consequences of your actions and de
ontology so duty serious to think you
judge it by your intentions and your
motives agree at least on this that I'm
wrong when I'm telling you about dirty
hands and I'm not gonna say a great deal
about that I'm going to point you to
some readings later on that you can go
in through yourself but there's a whole
story to be told about why I think they
not right in their criticism of me but I
can't go deeply into it just take it
from me for the moment on trust trust me
I'm a doctor
right that they don't agree with me and
there are arguments against them but I
am going to try a different route I'm
gonna go via the literary route and the
film route and then an example route and
see how your intuitions go and at the
end you might agree with me or you might
agree with the model theorist that would
be absolutely fine okay let's start off
here what does it mean to get dirty
hands then what what's what's a neat or
at least a plausible starting definition
that you can use that we can at least
get a grip on and try and work through
as we as we go through this topic well a
person gets dirty hands when they
violate an important moral value in
order to bring about a lesser evil in
moral conflict situations that's quite a
mouthful when we just try and unpack a
little bit for you we face situations
where we have moral conflicts or moral
dilemmas and in those situations the
options that the person who has to act
have are either bad or worse or
catastrophic and abysmal or whatever
kind of description you want given it
there isn't an option of good or bad if
there was an option of good or bad we
have got a problem we just do the good
but many situations in life we find
where our options are circumscribed
either by the evil actions of other
people or the morality of the people or
just by natural circumstances and there
we have to make a decision that's a very
painful one about
which evil to choose which you think
would be the least problematic but in
dirty hands situations the person who
dirty his hands becomes guilty of a
moral crime it's very famous ticking
bomb scenario many people think what is
the infamous ticking bomb scenario
because they think such a scenario and
this guides us into what we should think
but someone plants a bomb in the center
of London you've caught the person who's
done it they mocking you and saying it's
going to blow up and killed thousands of
people and ruin the city and financial
collapse and they won't tell you where
the bomb is and there's no way you can
evacuate should you torture them to try
and get the information which is not a
little simple thing to think about
people who torture are not civilized
torture is wrong always wrong punish
them yes but you don't torture them but
in these circumstances the evils are
such that you might think of torturing
and some people will say to you well
maybe if that person plant the bomb they
deserve to be tortured now no one
deserves to be tortured and even if
you're worried about that you can say
well don't torture the bomber torture
the Bombers child then you've got a real
problem right
because a child certainly doesn't
deserve to be tortured no one's gonna
argue that right so you have that kind
of that kind of moral crime I mean
that's an extreme example they mainly
other kinds that we can talk about but
I'm doing this rather quickly right
what's also interesting about dirty
hands is that the person who so acts
also gets praised for doing what's
courageous and difficult in a very
difficult scenario so it's paradoxical
in that sense you're both committing a
crime and doing something good we'll
come back to that in a moment and what's
more the person who becomes who does the
dirty hands becomes morally polluted
from the justified act of lying or
betraying or using violence or something
of that kind so you have this really
strange situation where a good person in
the situation there's something terrible
to bring about a lesser evil is now
guilty of a moral crime and as morally
polluted that's that's pretty scary okay
so that's that's what we mean in a broad
sense what we haven't dirty hands now
dirty hands occurs in all areas of our
lives and if I had time I'll give you
examples and our private life and all
return but where it occurs most most
often and most dramatically is in
politics and and for reasons I'm going
to explain at the moment politics if
it's not in nothing it's all about
compromise and when you compromise you
end up choosing lesser evils and because
you're choosing lesser evils you end up
getting a steady hands
I'm not suggesting at all cases of dirty
hands are as dramatic as the ticking
bomb you might just be involved in lying
who thinks of politicians at don't point
some point don't lie or dissemble or
stab their colleagues in the back yeah
I'm not even talking about what's going
on at the moment I'm just talking
generally right politicians do all those
kinds of things all the time because
that's the nature of politics or at
least it always has been the nature of
politics and probably will be with us
for a very long time so compromise is
endemic to politics and we never never
can have a situation where what you know
very rarely 'im situation where in
politics you don't have some kind of
dirty hand scenario going on what's more
politics also involves extrication
people pick up the messes of their
predecessors when obama became president
united states you inherited two wars and
anakin
crisis one of his making but he
inherited them he couldn't do the kinds
of things he wanted to do or his
instinct for him to do because he had to
extricate himself from the situation
that he inherited politics is are very
much about that and thirdly politics is
about protecting us from enemies both
internal external from the natural and
social evils that are out there and it's
difficult to behave morally in a world
where there are evil people and evil
organisations trying to harm us
sometimes you have to be in particular
you have to have means to bring about
certain ends and those means are not the
best or the most immoral means to get
there so you lie and you manipulate and
sometimes use violence to get the kinds
of things you need to do for worthwhile
ian's so politics is the natural home if
you like of dirty hands as I said it
doesn't mean it's the only place but
it's the natural home of dirty hands let
me turn to some pictures now to give you
a bit of a break from all this you find
the dirty hands premise in so many of
our movies and TV shows and books and
all over and I'll just give you a random
example from recent times those of you
that don't know what that is
have not been living on this planet
right millions of people all over the
world have been looking at this that is
Ned Stark sitting on the Iron Throne and
the premise of this movie amongst all
the other things with dragons and
zombies and all the rest it is that
there you had and I hope it's not gonna
be a spoiler so if if you haven't seen
anything of the first date first series
stick your fingers in your ears now and
golly laughter the next two minutes
right Ned Stone is a good man and his
goodness destroys it and that's not the
only problem being destroyed by his
goodness is not in the self a terrible
calamity this wouldn't for Ned enough
but everybody else who depended on him
to be more wily and cunning as a
politician are now going to suffer and
what you see in the game of Thrones is
the unfolding of his failure to some
degree right so there you had a person
who didn't get their hands dirty or
refuse to get the hands that he was
too stupid to get their hands dirty or
too good to identity and calamity around
hundreds of fingers in ears fingers in
ears hundreds of thousands of people we
think it but it died because of you plus
all the other hand twelve misery so
there's one case where underlying that
is the premise of what happens when you
have to deal with evil persons to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas